es ist eine gemeinsame entscheidung die
wir getroffen haben ich bediene ja nicht
die cdu multi media kanäle aber es ist
eine entscheidung dass wir gesagt haben
video das ist jetzt in dieser diskussion
nicht das richtige format wir wollen
keinen ewigen austausch jetzt über video
sondern lieber einen austausch auf einer
argumenten und sagte ich fühle mich
überhaupt nicht ausgebremst und meine
schlagfertigkeit ist in keiner weise
verloren
und das ärgerte auch nicht dass jetzt
ihr video nicht zum zuge kommen also ich
setze da nicht auf persönliche
eitelkeiten sondern auf sachliche
diskussion und das ist auch der richtige
anspruch und genau darum geht es auch am
sonntag bei der europawahl nicht darum
wer wann welche videos veröffentlicht
sondern um themen und da ist die cdu
sehr gut aufgestellt sie sagen immer wir
und wie sehen sie das persönlich das
sehe ich auch persönlich so dass diese
aussagen mache ich mir alle zu eigen
aber wissen sie das ist ja es geht ja in
der diskussion darum über die cdu auch
zu werden und da vertreten wir eine
gemeinsame position hat reese teilweise
recht also sicherlich ist es richtig zu
beklagen dass wir beim thema klimaschutz
unsere aktuellen zielstellung noch nicht
erreichen das ist auch für die cdu ein
zustand den ich gut finde und deswegen
arbeiten wir auch daran wie wir besser
werden können diese ziele zu erreichen
und das was völkerrechtlich zugesagt ist
das wollen wir auch schaffen
richtig ist aber dass in einer ganz
komplexen welt die antworten eben nicht
so einfach sind sondern dass wir schon
auch schauen müssen dass wir das
differenzieren und etwa beim thema
umwelt muss man auch sehen geht es
natürlich darum dass wir auch einen
strompreis haben müssen auch in den
nächsten monaten in den nächsten jahren
der noch bezahlbar bleibt auch für
diejenigen mit geringeren einkommen und
deswegen geht es darum dass wir
natürlich unser auf den weg gemacht
haben für die energiewende und natürlich
auch sagen wir wollen kohleausstieg und
anderes mehr aber wenn man dann sagt ja
bei diesem kohleausstieg das ist halt
einfach ein wandel der arbeitswelt da
muss man auch sagen dass sich nicht nur
zahlen von arbeitsplätzen sondern auch
menschen die in dieser region betroffen
sind